have you ever heard of ripple
yeah but they they're shady right
okay so ripple was this thing kind of
like started pretty early on um
and they had this like you know honestly
not a bad idea they were like look uh
you know the way the international
banking system works today is off this
thing called the swift standard ripple
was like we're gonna be a bank to bank
communication layer that uses blockchain
right so they're like we're gonna use
blockchain technology with a real use
case which is banks sending money back
forward to each other so that was their
idea they got a bunch of funding from
founders fund and others and they
released this thing called xrp that's
the name of their token all right so
whatever nobody cares about that how it
works nobody cares but the interesting
part is xrp has like was worth a lot the
founders of ripple became billionaires
overnight before
like that's the thing with crypto you
can get rich before like this open down
has 130 million before they have a
product
in ripple those guys became billionaires
before banks ever used their product
which is like a really up
incentive and which is why
sometimes doesn't actually get
built in crypto because hey i already
got the millions i could just run away i
could just do a half-assed job it
doesn't really matter at this point i
went public on day one
so
ripple
has a market cap right now of
94 is this right 94 billion dollars i
think i'm reading this right 94 billion
dollars something like that no no sorry
44 billion dollars 44 billion dollars
right that's like that's like the market
cap of like you know bank of america or
some like that so
obviously ripple's not actually valued
at that but ripple had believers and
they had early momentum they were very
early in the crypto games they had a lot
of pr and the ceo would go on cnbc and
talk about how this is going to change
the game so
what happened
in the crypto community people were kind
of like poo pooing riptile they're like
this is like centralized they they took
way too much share for themselves they
didn't give enough to users that's why
these guys are billionaires
their product kind of sucks and they're
kind of shady whatever whatever that's
the reputation was ripple anybody who
was in the know encrypted crypto pretty
much the general consensus was ripples
full of
and uh so my buddy had this idea he was
like he was like i'm gonna do the first
hostile takeover
of a crypto network i was like what do
you mean he goes look i can see every
single person's wallet who owns ripple
i was like okay that's kind of
interesting there you go i go but you
don't know their name and all that
because i don't need their name i was
like you don't have their email address
he goes i don't need their email address
i could just put something in their
wallet and they'll wake up and they'll
open their wallet and they'll see that
they have something in it i was like
okay he goes so i'm going to go out
there i'm going to say
xrp is stupid for these five reasons
number one the founders took when you
wait people anything
you can include include a message in the
transaction of
the thing
but like the way you do it is you first
drop the token you tell people hey if
you held ripple you got this token today
and then you write your manifesto on
your twitter or your website about what
this is all about so you it's kind of
like
somebody put a 50 check in your wallet
you're like what's this all about says
go to this website to explain why you
just got this 50 so that's how this
that's how this marketing mechanism
works
so he was like i'm gonna put some money
in there i'm gonna put my currency in
all the ripple holders wallet and then
i'm to tell them ripple is stupid for
these five reasons the founders took too
much this other problem this other prop
the you know their the right the token
is inflationary blah blah blah
so i'm going to change all that we only
take 10
we are not inflationary we do not do
this sketchy blah blah blah my
five-point plan of how to make ripple
better
um and we're we're calling it our own
thing and here's the deal if you own
ripple
if you send your ripple to my wallet
i will send you back five times your
value of this if you're in the first for
the first thousand people to do this
then for the next ten thousand people
that do this you're going to get four
times your your ripple back and for the
next ten thousand people you're going to
get three times the ripple back so
basically there's this urgency of like
okay if these if this is gonna become
the next ripple if i send my money in
now i'm gonna get five i'm gonna get a
5x multiplier of my money and what he
was gonna do was just he goes when you
send it to this wallet we're gonna just
dump it we're just gonna sell it and
we're gonna put so much cell pressure
we're going to crash the price of ripple
so if you do it and then do they do this
or so let me finish the story so he goes
if you do this early you're going to get
five times your amount
and you're not gonna sit there holding
the bag while we dump this thing it's
like a prisoner dilemma game through it
was so genius he's like
he's like here's the math if you're if
you're holding this thing you have to
assess
are other people going to take them up
on this offer if they do then the ripple
i'm holding is going to go down like
crazy
i'm going to go down like 5 to 10x if i
jump if i jump ship i get a 5x
multiplier on my money and i don't sit
there holding the sinking ship
and the game theory of this i think was
gonna work so he has his plan and he
starts and he starts uh and so he's like
okay well he needs to be credible so he
went to some very very wealthy people
and he got about 50 million dollars
lined up to do this hostile takeover and
he was like he needed it to be like 200
million and so he's like i need to
create this huge war chest so i can tell
people look we have this much money so
you this it's backed by something come
on board and he's like dude he's like
basically i'm going to this investor i'm
saying if you give me 200 million
dollars i'm going to take down this
project i'm going to absorb all the
value of this project that's currently
worth 40 billion
right so he's like it's a huge return
for those investors and they and they
also don't even believe in ripple so
what was this
high stakes james bond what
the problem was one of the investors
that he had went to for this
leaked the plan to a journalist
this guy uh dan primack or whatever he's
like pretty famous journalist yeah from
axios axios axios writes the story ahead
of time he says hey there's somebody
planning a hostile takeover xrp and
here's how it's gonna work
and
xrp obviously the ripple team obviously
sees this and they're like
okay just in case they so they sold
some amount of their ripple um to create
a like few hundred million dollar buffer
so that if somebody tried to do this and
tried to tank the price they had enough
liquidity to buy back the buy back the
tokens and keep the price high so it
kind of foiled his plan where the the
only the only way it would have worked
is if he had caught them by surprise
and he could have done it in like a
two-day period he could have tanked the
price of ripple and created this
competitor and had all the momentum on
his side but because they had heads up
they they could create enough liquidity
and they could be able to like support
their price before somebody could do
this to them but how crazy is that dude
this is like some barbarians at the gate
like this is like 1980s like drexel
um
like hostile takeover where they like
were like what's it called the green
mailing have you ever read like these
like 1980s finance i have i have the
book barbarian i haven't read it yet uh
yeah that's basically what they did like
it was like
it was like warfare and i was like this
is some george soros you know the
george soros broke the bank of england
that's actually what he was telling me
he goes this is some george soros i
was like what do you mean he goes george
soros broke the bank of england by doing
something very similar to this
and as he was explaining i was like
there's no way this works he's like well
you know it's risky but like if it works
who who did it and
so he didn't he didn't end up doing it
um but i mean who who's an artist is it
public
uh i don't know if it's public but i'll
tell you
it's our friend who remember we went to
dinner after our live show in miami it's
our friend yeah okay okay yeah
um
that's crazy i thought uh if if dan
would have wrote about it he would have
named him yeah i think he didn't know
the name or he i don't think he included
the name of the thing but how
nuts is that that's crazy if you get if
that person could have pulled it off
that's wild
this is bavarians at the gate
hostile takeover stuff yeah i love it
[Music]
you